jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
preuves par 3 en ce jour crucial pour
l'ump et même ses heures fatidiques
pourrait-on dire bonsoir monsieur le
premier ministre
bonsoir monsieur concise et à ce titre
que vous prenez effectivement la barre
de l'ump secoué par l'affairé bygmalion
avec deux autres anciens premiers
ministres françois fillon et alain juppé
bien sûr nous allons consacrer une large
partie de cette émission à l'ump plonger
dans les turbulences et qui réunira un
nouveau congrès ce sera à l'automne dans
quelles conditions bien vous allez
pouvoir nous le dira nous évoquerons
également la position plus que jamais
confortable du chef de l'état françois
hollande et puis parlera aussi de vos
ambitions pour le sénat avec jean lui
prévôt de la fp et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat d'abord bien sûr le départ
au sein d'une démission collective nous
avons bien compris de jean-françois copé
de la présidence de l'ump à l'issue d'un
bureau politique très tendu ce qui
l'attend est comme on le dit jusqu'au
bout de sauver sa tête où elle a été
très digne il a été dans un moment
particulièrement difficile dans une
atmosphère parfois insupportable
humainement affectivement insupportable
raison de coupures en détention des
démographes des inquiétudes de ce qu'il
y avait de tragique dans cette situation
et notamment par l'importance de cette
affaire qui a vraiment
inquiète et en même temps qui a jeté une
incompréhension et puis il a plaidé son
innocence avec conviction il a été
reconnu qu' il avait droit à sa
présomption d'innocence est donc très
dignement il a démissionné de sa
fonction et retrouve sa liberté il a
plaidé son innocence est ce que vous
avez tenté de l'aider vous
personnellement vous l'aimez bien c'est
votre expression jean françois copé
est-ce que vous avez tenté de défendre
je présente l'ump démissionnaire dans
ses dénégations
je n'ai pas un prix comme cela dans
cette intervention que j'ai eu à faire
j'ai parlé en fonction de ma conviction
j'ai dit combien j'étais effondrée par
les nouvelles que que j'apprenais j'ai
dit combien notre parti étaient menacés
par un risque de disparition et qu'il
fallait mettre l'unité du parti au
dessus de tout et que pour les tic
il y avait une ligne qui s'imposaient à
tous qu'il fallait se rassembler et
qu'il fallait que jean françois copé en
son âme et conscience nous disent
qu'est-ce qu'il souhaitait faire et donc
je n'ai pas voulu que nous le fassions
il a fait un grand travail dans l'ue ont
pu observer les élections municipales il
a fallu former des candidats à les
sélectionner
il a fallu faire beaucoup de choses
pendant ces deux ans donc il a fait un
travail il a pris sa responsabilité en
son âme et conscience du moment de
manière viable il responsabilités il
annoncé il a annoncé dès le début qu'il
écouterait tout le monde et qu'il dirait
sa conclusion à la fin lorsqu'il a tenté
je dois à proposer des concessions non
ils ont vu son nom il était pas dans
cette danse est je dirais état d'esprit
il était vraiment dans un état d'esprit
de gravité comme nous tous il répondait
à ce que nous disions il y avait des
attaques plus féroces les unes que les
autres
il y avait et qui vous a
particulièrement saint georges et je ne
veux pas je ne veux pas dû parler de ce
que j'ai entendu mais qui avait quelques
fois des mots durs mais au total il y
avait quand même du respect la du
respect pour la personne de jean
françois copé de son ex alors le coup
est rude pour lui bien évidemment et ce
qu'il va s'en remettre selon vous ça je
le crois je pense que lille a une
énergie exceptionnelle ce reviendra je
pense que jean françois copé n'est pas
sorti de la scène politique il a un
talent il a une volonté et puis il a
maintenant cette conscience en lui même
de son innocence et donc ça lui donne
une force vous les croyez que cette
force il devra il devra l'exprimer donc
je pense qu'il l'exprimera même en ne
croyez quand il se dit innocent avec la
connaissance de ce qui s'est passé avec
ses comptes truqués les phosphatiers je
suis effondré par les nouvelles mais je
suis respectueux de cette présomption
d'innocence et je dois comme tout le
monde faire confiance à la fois à jean
françois copé est un homme responsable
qu'il est et à la justice de nous dire
la vérité c'est à la justice de dignité
aujourd'hui jean pierre raffarin diriger
l'ump ça veut dire collaborer avec la
justice ouvrir les portes les tiroirs
les armoires vais devoir répondre aux
sollicitations
ça veut dire chercher la vérité mais je
crois qu'il faut que la
vérité sorte il faut qu'on sache
exactement ce qui s'est passé et comment
les choses se sont passées qui a décidé
quoi
et donc on a besoin de cette vérité et
on a besoin de coopérer avec la justice
de la manière la plus transparente vous
pourriez répondre aux questions d'un
joli je pense que la police et la
justice doivent avoir des conditions de
travail qui soit complètement ouverte
pour tout homme et à sa disposition nous
mettons notre organisation à la
disposition de la police et de la
justice mais ça a déjà été fait par jean
françois copé est donc cesser la ligne
parce que ce qu'ils en avaient tous deux
commun ils compris jean françois copé
c'est que tout le monde veut la vérité
parce que jean françois copé aussi lui
qui dit clairement qu'il n'était pas
informé veut savoir ce qui s'est passé
donc il y a un besoin de vérité partagez
vous vous dites notamment effondré par
la nature des révélations n'est ce pas
jean pierre à fermer ce qu'on peut
croire par l'ampleur et ampleur par
l'ampleur des sommes concernées c'est
quelque chose te mens est ce qu'on peut
croire qu'un tel dépassement des comptes
de campagne de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 dont plus de 10
millions d'euros ait pu passer inaperçue
écoutez moi je ne suis ni juge ni les
magistrats ni expert comptable il se
trouve qu'on est dans une procédure
judiciaire que la justice nous dise la
vérité
moi je veux la vérité et je compte sur
la justice pour établir la vérité et
c'est elle qui nous fera conclure les
prendre les décisions que nous devons
rendre ce qu'ils savaient et est
forcément plus nombreux que ceux très
peu compris d'ailleurs aujourd'hui qui
porte un chapeau trop grand pour eux non
écoutez si sur ce sujet moi je ne veux
pas dire autre chose que ce qu'on dit
les personnes intéressées qui ont parlé
avec une sincérité souvent touchantes et
bien donc que la justice maintenant avec
ces différents témoignages nous dise la
vérité et ne nous comportons pas ni en
procureur ni en juge cette affaire
confiance à notre justice pour élucider
cette affaire
est ce que ces révélations compliquer le
retour éventuel de nicolas sarkozy
je pense que nicolas sarkozy mène une
réflexion qui n'est pas achevée de toute
façon son parcours était en grande
partie extérieure à l'ump
donc nous verrons bien c'est là qu'on
voit que j'étais financé en partie par
le m'écouter on va voir ce que va dire
la justice mais n'anticipons pas sur ce
que dira la justice pour le moment il
faut sauver l'unité de l'ump pour que
nous restions rassembler parce que nous
avons une espérance a porté sur
l'alternance des dans ce pays et donc il
nous faut être capable de à la fois
d'avoir une forte éthique pour l'avenir
de notre parti est en même temps une
bonne gouvernance pour gérer les
échéances à venir alors l'éthique c'est
notamment respecter les plafonds de
dépenses pour les campagnes jean pierre
raffarin
marine le pen estime que l'ancien chef
de l'état est disqualifié je pense que
naturellement dans cette affaire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui calcule il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
extrêmement sincère de tous leurs
contres mais là en l'occurrence madame
le pen donc moi je ne veux pas
participer à ce jeu de massacre
je vois bien que nous avons une
situation difficile à affronter
il faut l'affronter avec courage ce que
nous avons fait ce matin avec dignité et
éthique et d'avoir confiance dans la
justice et surtout chercher la vérité je
sais ce que par exemple nicolas sarkozy
est exposé à un risque d'inéligibilité
pour demain je ne peux pas vous dire
c'est injustice à dire alors je ne peux
pas je ne veux pas que le bureau
politique ce matin ne s'est pas fait
juge ni magistrat ce n'est pas à nous
maintenant de d'être un juge magistrat
c'est à la justice de dire ce qu'il en
est nous nous devons veiller à ce que
les règles de l'éthique soit respectée
de a à z c'est vrai que le nom de
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas été prononcé ce
mardi matin lors de votre bureau
politique
je n'en ai pas souvenir il a pu l'être
mais je n'ai pas souvenir alors vous
voilà donc chargé d'une mission
d'intérim maison que je le disais tout à
l'heure avec alain juppé françois fillon
mais vous allez aussi devoir jouer les
arbitres en fait entre deux
présidentiables donc deux rivaux vous
allez être le juge de paix également
entre ces deux là écoutez les conditions
ne sont pas encore définis pour cette
gouvernance intérimaire
je pense que nous aurons d'ici le 15
juin un ou deux bureaux politiques
je pense que nous devons veiller à ce
que nos décisions soient compatibles
avec nos statuts et avec notre haute
autorité avec madame levade qui doit
nous dire précisément quel est le
calendrier des décisions que nous devons
prendre et donc nous avons pris une
décision politique aujourd'hui il faut
au prochain bureau politique on met en
forme juridiquement cette décision dans
le calendrier quelles sont les missions
exactes de l'intérim
parce que la terrible n'est pas une
présidence et définitive donc il ya des
responsabilités qui doivent être
définies ça nous savons et puis les
précautions qui devront être prises pour
le congrès pour le prochain scrutin
berne à jean françois copé a mis en
place cette haute autorité cette haute
autorité va nous donner les règles et
nous les respecterait ce que françois
fillon tient déjà depuis aujourd'hui sa
revanche je ne crois pas qu'il faut voir
dans le show il faut pas voir les choses
comme ça et je pense que si on aurait
tort de les voir comme ça parce que ça
voudrait dire que les tensions déjà un
certain temps perdure je pense qu'il
faut voir aujourd'hui que nous sommes
dans une crise et que nous devons
organiser la survie de notre famille
politique autour de ses valeurs
autour de ses ambitions et de ses
projets et donc pour cela il faut faire
en sorte qu'on se rassemble
moi je suis l'un de ceux à l'ump qui
parle à françois fillon qui parut
assurément jean françois copé qui parle
à nicolas sarkozy donc moi je tisse des
liens avec alain juppé et avec les
autres et je fais en sorte que la
famille reste rassuré car je sais que ce
qui conduit à l'échec c'est la division
est ce que françois fillon pour être
candidat à la présidence de l'ump à
l'automne s'il se présente comme il l'a
annoncé à la primaire
il me dit nous sommes des libéraux il
n'y a pas de règle à ce jour et najib
andy lui pas pour moi c'est non bon
c'est ce que dit alain juppé nous en
discuterons nous n'avons pas encore
discuté puisque je vous dis que je veux
l'unité donc je chercherai une règle
commune
mais il est clair que aujourd'hui je
pense que françois fillon des qualités
pour assumer un certain nombre de
responsabilités
alain juppé aussi comme jean françois
copé en avait aussi donc nous définirons
ensemble et règles que chacun y aura les
respecte est ce que il faut avancer la
primaire c'est ce que certains réclament
à l'ump par exemple font crise en crise
terminée dès 2015
j'aime beaucoup franck riester qui est
un homme politique de grand talent et de
hautes responsabilités sur ce point je
ne suis pas d'accord avec lui parce que
le problème est que la personne qui
sortira de la primaire devra être en
face dans l'opinion pour la
présidentielle et donc rien ne nous dit
que la personnalité qui sera en phase
avec l'opinion en printemps 2015 sera la
même personne
il faudra avoir au printemps 2010 est
donc moi je pense qu'il faut faire comme
ça a été prévu dans nos statuts la
primaire en 2016 est ce que vous croyez
qu'une telle affaire jette des
bataillons de militants de l'ump dans
les bras de marine le pen c'est un des
sujets sur lesquels nous avons réfléchi
et qui nous a imposé ses décisions qui
sont au total douloureuse parce que je
pense qu'il y avait des risques de
départ au centre et de départ à droite
et donc il y avait ceux de ce danger là
et c'est pour ça que j'ai milité pour
que l'on recherche
aujourd'hui l'union dans notre famille
politique et qu'on puisse être assemblés
et notre décision collective ce matin a
été l'occasion d'une position commune
est-ce que marine le pen ne s'installe
pas finalement après ces chocs en
cascade comme la seule opposante où la
principale opposante à françois hollande
et elle est une opposante à françois
hollande ce qu'elle essaie d'établir
aujourd'hui c'est sa présence au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
mais je pense que encore on l'a vue
fortement avec les municipales on le
voit avec les européennes
s'il y avait un match de second tour
aujourd'hui ils seraient entre
front national et l'ump et donc la
situation pour l'ump ne serait pas
fortement défavorable et vous savez il
faut se méfier des élections européennes
vous avez peut-être noté qu'il y avait
une élection législative à toulouse et
que à toulouse il y a une participation
police hâtive de 51% alors qu'elle est
beaucoup plus faible aux européennes est
notre candidat gagne le poste de député
à toulouse avec une nette majorité donc
on voit bien que l'élection législative
n'est pas l'élection européenne
donc madame le pen évidemment en faisant
ce score nous pose un problème politique
majeur
mais je crois qu'elle profite surtout de
l'effondrement du parti socialiste est
aujourd'hui en pleine affaire big band
lyon certains au parti socialiste estime
que c'est un coup terrible pour la
république vous êtes d'accord avec cette
vision et cette formule moi je pense le
pen profite pas au parti républicain
je pense que du socialiste mettre un
petit peu d'huile sur le feu sur tout
cela est au fond c'est sans doute leur
intérêt ce n'est pas forcément une
hauteur de vue exceptionnel sur tout
dans la situation dans laquelle ils sont
après un effondrement électorale majeure
est dans une situation politique où le
président de la république dans le
sentiment d'être très absent même quand
il fait une intervention télévisée 7
cette intervention marque pas les
esprits alors justement nous allons jean
pierre raffarin évoqué maintenant le
sort de françois hollande et puis son
intervention au lendemain de ce scrutin
européen qui était une débâcle pour le
parti socialiste et pas du tout une
réussite pour l'ump plus inconfortable
que jamais donc la situation du chef de
l'état peut-il encore réformé peut-il
encore gouverné avant d'accueillir jean
louis prévost de l' agence france-presse
état des lieux à l'elysée avec faustine
saint geniès ce vote c'est une défiance
à l'égard de l'europe une prise de
parole qui s'apparente à un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
même à l'elysée tout le monde n'était
pas d'accord sur son opportunité
le chef de l'état fait face à une
situation intenable après la débâcle de
dimanche
tentative d'explication de ces quatre
minutes d'intervention solennel à 20
heures françois hollande a essayé sur la
forme à la fois
de jouer la présidentialité il est dans
la bibliothèque de l'elysée est à la
fois par sa gestuelle de montré une
combativité alors évidemment c'est au
service du moment à l'issue d'une crasse
défaite électorale le fait que le front
national arrive en première position
pas question de changer de politique la
ligne vient juste d'être défini un
nouveau premier ministre vient juste
d'être nommé bref il faut maintenir le
cap
quel est-il annoncé de nouvelles mesures
tous les jours une nouvelle mesure
non le cap est fixé c'est celui du
redressement de la france dans la
justice le cap est fixé c'est celui
d'une meilleure répartition de la
richesse de cap est fixé c'est jure de
la baisse d'impôt pour les couches
populaires et les classes moyennes c'est
ça la réalité
pourtant le moral des troupes est au
plus bas au parti socialiste
chez les députés l'ambiance était
glaciale ce mardi et les critiques ont
fusé en présence de manuel valls
l'un d'eux a même évoqué un problème
françois hollande
je pense qu'on attend du président a vu
qu'aujourd'hui plus que sa déclaration
d'hier c'est qu'ils affichent clairement
ce qu'est l'intention de la france il
est probable que sa déclaration était
d'abord destiné à rassurer ses voisins
européens parce que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure il n'avait pas
vraiment de nécessité au plan national
françois hollande plus affaiblie que
jamais participent aujourd'hui à un
dîner informel à bruxelles
un numéro d'équilibriste en perspective
pour une france en perte d' influence
voilà jean lui prêtant des fêtes avec
nous pour son argent lui vos questions à
jean pierre raffarin bonsoir monsieur
raffarin alors la déclaration de
françois hollande hier vous nous dites
il est venu pour ne rien dire
je pense que
on pouvait attendre d'une intervention
du président de la république en cette
situation de gravité politique avec le
score du front national
un message qui soit à la fois plus
vigoureux et en même temps un certain
nombre de réflexions sur la situation du
pays et notamment sur ses deux priorités
qui devraient être certes l'emploi
mais pour le moment je ne vois pas venir
le fameux pacte de responsabilité que
nous attendons toujours depuis le 14
janvier
ça va faire bientôt six mois d'annoncés
sans action et puissent deuxièmement
qu'ils nous proposent des initiatives
institutionnelles je pense pour
réconcilier les français et la politique
parce que le vote de dimanche
ça veut dire que vous journalistes et
moi politique on est en partie coupé du
pays
et ça c'est un vrai problème républicain
et moi j'attends que le président de la
république dise comment on va rapprocher
le politique de la langue de la belgique
où lui proposez quoi nous suggérer quoi
rapprocher je pense qu'il ne pourra pas
se contenter de son big bang territorial
alors quoi et encore son big bang
territorial faudrait-il qu'ils le
charisme tout à l'heure avec mary est
sûre je pense qu'il faut moderniser le
parlement par exemple il faut un
parlement plus efficace et il faut
rénover le sénat il faut dynamiser
l'assemblée nationale il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont à faire alors il y at il
un problème hollande comme certains le
disent au psg trouvait le président de
la république très absent il est un peu
en suspension dans notre débat politique
je trouve que il a des bonnes
interventions épisodiquement
mais entre deux interventions on ne voit
pas l'action on ne voit pas ni la
perspective est ni la recherche du
résultat
alors vous êtes je crois qu'il n'a pas
réussi à inverser la courbe de
l'efficacité du passage à l'acte
je crois que c'est un bon analyste mais
que sur le plan de l'acte il est un
subtil encore les moyens d'agir de moins
en moins c'est pour ça que ça les choses
vont devenir difficiles c'est que de
moins en moins la capacité d'action
d'abord déjà dans un quinquennat
c'est au début que se font les réformes
le plus lourd est donc cette au début
qu'on met les grands chantiers
et en plus quand on est à ce degré
d'impopularité et de désaveu l'action
devient difficile alors vous voulez dire
qu'il pourrait ne pas achever son
quinquennat non je ne pense pas nous
avons des institutions très forte mais
en tout cas ce que je crains c'est que
les choses continuent comme elles sont
en train de se passer c'est à dire que
le président intervient la télévision ça
n'intéresse pas grand monde
au total tout ceci passe comme sur une
toile cirée ça cool mais ça ne marque
pas ça n'imprime pas la question
fondamentale est ce que le président de
la république veut oui ou non
incarner la france quand il va voter en
voiture avec eux c'est ça que les
français demandent au président
république d'aller passer dix heures
dans une voiture pour aller voter
personne n'en voudra auprès d'un public
de prendre son avion d'aller voter et de
vie de rentrer à l'elysée pour
travailler et le ressort de plus normal
de prendre la voiture c'est au fond pour
un président le refus d'assumer cette
fonction exceptionnelle qui est
l'incarnation de la france basculement
est ce que le premier ministre manuel
valls incarne plus sa fonction selon
groulx parce que lui il a tenu un
discours presque présidentielle dans le
ton dès dimanche soir vous avez noté bon
j'ai noté présidentielle c'est beaucoup
dire
c'est beaucoup de noms mais s'était
d'ailleurs les deux discours aurait été
utile s'il avait été prononcée peut-être
pendant la campagne électorale pour le
score du parti socialiste parce que ils
ont fait les discos comme ça au moment
où les bureaux de vote sont fermés ce
qui n'est pas très efficace mais sur le
plan de la rade la relation entre
matignon et l'elysée
il est clair que manuel valls a
aujourd'hui une dynamique est en fait
une volonté d'imprimer son sa
responsabilité sur le terrain dans
l'action ça va poser un problème un
moment ou un autre si le président ne
réagit pas ce l'envié est ce que
françois hollande a raison de marteler
comme le fait manuel valls qu'il n'y a
qu'une ligne et on s'y tient
bien sûr le président de la république
est celui qui fixe le cap et donkey
c'est lui qui fixe la ligne mais le
problème c'est que quand il dit le 14
janvier
je veux un pacte de responsabilité qu'on
ne se retrouve pas à la mi juin
sans rien à boire de tout ce qu'il a
annoncé parce que l'emploi je vois ça
dans mon département de la vienne et mes
collègues sénateurs sont nombreux à
chaque mardi à notre réunion du groupe
on fait la liste des entreprises en
difficulté on voit toutes les
difficultés qu'ont les pme aujourd'hui
et bien perdre six mois c'est une grave
faute politique
quand il s'agit d'emplois vous avez un
programme d'urgence pour lui je pense
qu'il ya pas mal de choses qui seraient
assez nécessaire très vite oui comme
lesquels a par exemple la jal en charge
ils sont décidés ces 30 milliards
pourquoi attendre pour les engagés par
exemple quelque chose qui ne coûte rien
doubler tous les seuils le seuil de 50
ans mais ressent le seul 200 la 207
effectifs des entreprises les essais qui
bougeait plus facile pour embaucher plus
facilement mais aussi pour certaines
cotisations
il y à il ya un série de seuil qui
aujourd'hui frais de développement et
free doit suspendre la réforme pénale de
christiane taubira
je pense qu'il ferait mieux de en effet
d'avoir des gestes de cette nature pour
rassembler sur les sépare je crois tout
à fait et responsable que d'annoncer une
réforme qui permette le droit de vote
des étrangers à quelques jours d'une
élection européenne je pense qu'il y a
des textes de lois qui sont aujourd'hui
agitée pour être des symboles politiques
quand on est à deux ans de
responsabilités que tu as trois ans la
prochaine échéance qu'est ce qu'on
attend de notre président sait qu'il
agit je vais vous dire très franchement
ma conviction c'est la faiblesse du
président ne sert personne
nous n'avons pas intérêt aux échecs du
président de la république parce que les
échecs du président sont les échecs de
la france et doutez-vous qu'il a encore
des chances pour 2017
il ne fait pas grand chose pour les
améliorer ses chances par définition je
suis
réaliste et je connais les instituts sur
la vème république la fonction est très
intelligent ce président ne peut changer
absolument un président a toujours une
puissance institutionnels réel mais il
faut dire que la situation aujourd'hui
du président de la république est
catastrophique
je pense dans son action mais je pense
aussi dans son attitude et dans la
capacité qu'il a a refusé d'incarner la
france de ses outils constitutionnels
c'est la dissolution mais vu l'état de
l'ump se serait pas forcément une
opportunité pour vous ce qu'elle serait
quand même souhaitable pour sortir de
cette quasi crise c'est votre mot à une
quasi crise présidentielle
oui je pense que la situation est grave
pour le président de la république les
graves à l'international c'est lui qui
est confronté à la perte de crédibilité
de la france vis-à-vis de tous les
grands dirigeants du monde donc il va
sentir quand il va être au sommet
européen dans le regard des autres dans
l'attitude est observée dans les
relations internationales le rapport de
force ça compte
on se regarde dans les yeux on va à
lorient les joueurs brugeois bien celui
qui est fort est celui qui est faible
donc lui même il va ressentir cette
faiblesse de la france dans ses
relations en béton il veut réorienter
l'europe bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites sur
le débat européen il faut qu'on se
remette tous en cause avec ce résultat
nous mêmes les européens nous devons
nous remettre en cause parce que nos
arguments ne passe pas on voit bien que
quand on parle de la paix quand on parle
de la force continentale de l'europe
on voit bien que tout ceci n'est
intéresse pas suffisamment n'ai pas
compris donc il faut que les européens
se remettent eux aussi en cause pour
reconstruire un message européen alors
justement il avancé une idée que l'union
européenne devra se retirer de là où
elle n'est pas nécessaire est ce que
vous approuvez cette île ça ça fait 20
ans qu'on dit ça y est on ne le fait pas
le problème aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir de
l'influencé pour convaincre madame
merkel c'est de la force qu'il faut
c'est pas de dire au claf la france
aujourd'hui voudraient ceci voudrait
cela il faut pouvoir convaincre madame
merkel d'abord il faut ensuite
convaincre les 27 autres et donc il y a
cette nécessité aujourd'hui d'être fort
d'avoir une influence diplomatique le
pouvoir aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas une capacité individuelle
c'est une capacité collective celle
influence sur un groupe dans l'europe et
donc il faut pas faire croire aux
français que c'est un président français
à lui seul change il change s'il arrive
à d'abord incombent à l'allemagne
et s'il arrive à séduire les autres
c'est le monde des états et maintenant
la france vu de l'étranger avec un front
national 25% des suffrages exprimés ces
nouvelles tâches là sur notre image je
pense que la france va souffrir de stage
je me souviens quand l'autriche avaient
voté pour l'extrême droite
combien elle avait souffert quant à son
image internationale donc c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
moi je dis clairement à nous français
qui nous écoutent que j'ai entendue
depuis dimanche beaucoup de bavardages
et vu naturellement beaucoup de calculs
mais j'ai vu peu de remise en cause
moi je pense que les européens doivent
se remettre en cause je pense qu'une des
raisons de notre faiblesse il faut y
réfléchir c'est qu'on ne parle pas
suffisamment de la mondialisation de
notre pays on est le seul pays
aujourd'hui qui parle de
démondialisation qui a une vision
idéologique de la mondialisation
or en fait la mondialisation c'est quoi
c'est la chine plus le brésil plus les
états unis poussent le canada c'est à
dire des gens qui défendent des intérêts
donc quand on dit on va faire une
mondialisation ceux ci on va faire une
mondialisation cela est ce qu'on est
capable de faire changer la chine est ce
qu'on est capable de faire changer le
brésil non
la mondialisation est là et la
dialectique qui se développe en france
et le choix entre eux la france et
l'europe
à mon avis c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est la france et le monde
et quand on regarde la france dans le
monde à ce moment là on s'aperçoit qu'on
a besoin de l'europe et donc je crois
que ce qui est très important c'est
qu'on réfléchisse c'est peut-être pas la
bonne solution mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on change notre dit ce qu il faut
après un vote comme ça se remettre en
cause je pense que le gouvernement
devrait remettre en cause toutes ces
réformes qui sont des dires forme de
diversion qui ne sont pas selon leurs
notes par émission par exemple critiqué
qui devrait et qui devrait se concentrer
le gouvernement sur l'emploi sur la
dynamique économique
je pense que nous dans l'opposition
notamment les européens on a un travail
à faire pour rendre notre message plus
moderne c'est pas normal que les jeunes
aujourd'hui n'est pas le goût de
l'europe qu'il faut réfléchir à cela
et c'est pas les jeunes qui ont tort
c'est nous qui ne savons pas à l'heure
présente et l'europe comme il le faut et
donc il faut qu'on réfléchisse à sa
aussi remise en cause et puis il faut
sans doute remettre en cause aussi très
clairement ce score du front national je
vous le disais quand vous voyez le
résultat des législatives de toulouse on
vous dit c'est parce que finalement les
gens disent aux municipales je vois tu
ump mais aux européennes je vote
notamment pour le front national et
surtout si je suis de gauche
n'oublions pas que jamais le front
national n'est plus fort quand la gauche
est de prévoir où la présence de marine
le pen au second tour en 2017 n'est pas
une fatalité
ce n'est pas une fatalité mais c'est une
responsabilité de la gauche de la gauche
par sa politique et quelquefois par sa
malice contribuer au développement du
front national exemple le droit de vote
des étrangers
à quelques jours du vote mais ça ne lui
profite plus on l'a vu merci jean louis
prévost il est le parti socialiste est
la première victime de cette stratégie
perrine tarneaud de public sénat arrive
pour évoquer bien notamment une réforme
peut-être même la réforme sur laquelle
compte françois hollande pour laisser
son empreinte on va en parler maintenant
c'est la nouvelle carte de la france ce
un mur de chine c'est un peu cette
dernière carte à jouer
celle d'une france redécouper après un
big bang territorial
françois hollande ne changera pas plus
de 4 que des kits gouvernementale la
rupture réclamé viendra donc de la
réforme territoriale
les choses vont aller assez vite une
fois que le président a parlé des textes
sont en préparation d'ores et déjà
qu'ils seront soumis au conseil des
ministres avant la fin du mois de juin
et on va essayer de commencer à débattre
de cette question de cette grande
réforme initiée au sénat parce qu'on
commence toujours par le sénat quand il
s'agit des territoires en juillet la
réforme aura lieu en deux temps d'abord
diviser le nombre de régions par deux
d'ici 2017 puis une possible suppression
des départements d'ici 2021 et c'est là
le principal risque de blocage
le groupe sur ce sujet reste très
protéiforme
pour ne pas dire diviser j'entends tous
les avis et des avis qui sont souvent
divergents voire contraire j'entends
ceux qui disent qu'il faut maintenir des
cantons des départements à tout prix
ceux qui disent qu'on peut très bien
faire une réforme qui ira au delà tout
cela c'est possible disparition des
conseils généraux d'ici 2021 divise les
sénateurs socialistes
les élus des territoires ruraux sont
inquiets le gouvernement serait donc
prêt à moduler la réforme pour préserver
le rôle des élus dans les zones rurales
pour la discussion que nous avons eue
avec manuel valls il nous a semblé qu'il
voulait prendre en compte justement
cette diversité des territoires et faire
en sorte que ce qu'on applique dans les
métropoles
on ne l'appliquent pas dans des zones
plus rurales
mais même dans les zones urbaines
impossible de supprimer les conseils
généraux sans réviser la constitution
l'exécutif pense avoir trouvé la parade
en maintenant des conseils généraux
vidés de leur substance
mais pour les spécialistes cette
manoeuvre serait retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel
on peut pas vidé de sa substance que les
départements tous les départements en
particulier ont leurs hôtes en leur
assemblée délibérante sans leur laisser
un minium de compétences donc le dans ce
cadre là il faut passer par une révision
constitutionnelle une révision
constitutionnelle qui nécessiterait soit
un référendum difficile à faire
approuver pour un exécutif aussi
impopulaire soit un vote du congrès où
le président n'est pas sûr d'obtenir la
majorité nécessaire pour le chef de
l'état nous dise aux questions sur ce
thème et d'autres encore bon alors on
l'a vu dans ce reportage
les sénateurs socialistes qui sont
visiblement un peu pris de court le
projet de loi sur la décentralisation
notamment sur les régions va être
examiné en conseil des ministres la
semaine prochaine il devrait être
examiné par le sénat au début du mois de
juillet ce qui est un risque le sénat de
gauche s'oppose au gouvernement sur ce
projet qui tient ses formes puisque vous
avez pris de court mais en fait on
assiste à une complète improvisation
parce que le président la république
ceux du début de l'année prod épartement
puis anti département on supprime la
cause de compétence générale
on remet la côte de compétence générale
ont supprimé la cause
on est dans une situation
d'improvisation et au fond il n'y a pas
de
vision sur le sujet le sénat avait
pourtant fait le travail
on avait fait une émission rapport qui a
été cité à plusieurs reprises on avait
l'air en disant il ya deux grandes
perspectives où vous faites des grandes
régions et vous gardez le département
pour la proximité et la grande région
c'est la puissance la grande région a
fait les grandes infrastructures
elle fait les éléments de stratégie et
le département il fait la proximité
schéma un schéma deux fusions ou
rapprochements région département et à
ce moment là plus département mais un
seul une seule collectivités région
département
ça c'était la logique du conseiller
territorial de nicolas sarkozy le parti
socialiste a fait une croix sur ce
projet et là maintenant il nous dit
grande région mais suppression des
départements
ça fait 1 suppression des départements
c'est encore un petit peu flou
visiblement on veut garder les conseils
généraux mais les vider de leur
substance sur les vider de leur
substance
cette dangereux de les vider de leur
substance parce que quand leur substance
c'est le social c'est la proximité la
cohésion sociale ça compte beaucoup dans
notre pays moi ce que je crains derrière
tout ça c'est que ce soit l'acte 1 de la
recentralisation
parce qu'on va redonner à l'état un
certain nombre de compétences si on les
enlève au département parce que vider de
leur substance de toute façon vous
n'allez pas vider le rsa vous allez bien
continuer la prime pour les handicapés
vous avez bien continuer un certain
nombre de prestations sociales ça veut
dire que l'état le ferais ça s'appelle
de la recentralisation actuel de la
recentralisation et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter la remise en cause du
département le département
c'est le lieu républicain de la
proximité sur 7 septembre qu'avait dit
jean françois copé oui oui vous voulez
les supprimer jean françois copé faisait
partie
non mais il faisait partie à l'intérieur
de l'ump d'une minorité qui est
favorable à la suppression des
départements
nous nous sommes au sénat dans le groupe
ump unanime maintien du département et
du sénat qui va fixer la ligne de l'ump
en matière de décentralisation c'est
laisser l'esprit de la vème république
puisque sur une réforme
constitutionnelle que j'ai fait voter
les textes de collectivités
territoriales viennent d'abord au sénat
donc la première expression politique de
l'ump
serein le groupe ump du sénat et nous
fixons notre ligne mais notre ligne elle
est très majoritaire quasiment unanime à
l'intérieur du groupe
le maintien du département et pour
éviter les doublons il toutes les
régions qui sont trop petit et qui ont
tendance à cantonaliser leurs actions à
se comporter comme des départements à ce
moment là il faut les agrandir parce
qu'on regarde tous les échelons non je
regardais pas les tous les échelons
parce que non non vous ne gardez pas
quand comme quand vous supprimez par
deux le nombre de régions déjà vous vous
avez une division par nourrir tout le
reste ou non papa vous pouvez très bien
supprimée dans certains cas par exemple
départements en milieu urbain nous
parlons là notamment d'améliorer la
position du gouvernement sur ce sujet la
consolante ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est montré omniprésent ce qui s'est
passé à lyon et quelque chose
d'acceptable puisque c'était voter par
un certain d'entre nous donc on peut
discuter une star mais est donc ce que
nous disons c'est que nous avons besoin
d'un espace de proximité la république
c'est de la proximité c'est pas une
question de niveau de collectivités
territoriales c'est une question
républicaine où le citoyen se re perty
quand le citoyen ne comprend pas la
démocratie est malade mais justement ce
que l'on doit s'exprimer pour un peu
plus de clarté sur ce dossier ce que
vous attendez de lui une parole claire
bien sûr on en attend du président de la
république sur ce sujet une vision et la
rochelle bon ce que nous voulons c'est
qu'une vraie vision stratégique parce
que si je prends les interventions
depuis le mois de janvier
c'est une politique en zigzag des allers
et retours département région va pouvoir
faire l'impasse d'une révision
constitutionnelle selon vous je ne le
crois pas où cette réforme est ambitieux
il faut changer la constitution ou alors
c'est de la cosmétique et là ce sera
très grave parce que les français ont
compris que ce big bang à ce moment-là
deviendrait une réforme diversion pour
occuper les territoires pour occuper le
débat politique parce que naturellement
tout le monde parle du découpage de sa
région etc mais ne traite pas le vrai
problème que le problème de l'emploi des
pme des artisans de l'agriculture de la
vie économique du pays
attention à ce que cette réforme ne soit
pas une réforme de diversion c'est le
regroupement des régions qu'avez vous
pensé des propositions ségolène royal
qui veut fusionner les pays de la loire
avec votre région du poitou charentes
je trouve que depuis qu'elle est
ministre elle a beaucoup de bonnes idées
et donc la souplesse à ses dirigeants je
pense que nous devons écouter les
habitants je pense que il faut pas se
comporter en féodaux et donc de dire
tiens je vais discuter avec les pays de
la loire et puis moi je fais une
alliance poitou charentes puis d'avoir
faut regarder les stratégies vont
regarder l'économie la vie des gens et
notamment les bassins de vie moi ce que
je peux vous dire par exemple pour une
région comme poitou-charentes sait que
traditionnellement notre histoire c'est
d'être le nord du sud donc plutôt
appartenir au sud mais dans est le nord
il se trouve qu'en aquitaine la capitale
bordeaux est au nord de l'aquitaine donc
la capitale bordeaux est un peu à mi
chemin d'un axe qui pourrait être le
nord de poitiers et la bonne ville de
pau est donc là on a en aquitaine
une qu'une image une capitale régionale
qui seraient à peu près centre a donc ça
nous paraît être un projet avec le
limousin mais ça me gêne fixe rien c'est
à la population de d'apprécier de
discuter et je ne veux pas me comporter
en grand féodal depuis dimanche soir
pour répondre à la colère des électeurs
vous proposer un big bang
institutionnels alors moderniser le
parlement rénover le sénat attention
vous allez faire peur aux sénateurs je
pense que les sénateurs ont peur car si
vous mettez en cause deux départements
vous mettez en cause le sénat en grande
partie parce que le sénat à sept bases
républicaines que celle du département
je pense qu'on a besoin d'un ces deux-là
fort on a besoin d'un sénat qui a la foi
propose mais aussi qui sait résister qui
est capable d'éviter des bêtises j'ai vu
dans le passé récent des bêtises qui son
père croyez vous qu aujourd'hui le sénat
de deux doigts doit-elle se doit ce
doigté tient aujourd'hui nous ne
connaissons pas les dates des prochaines
élections
nous ne connaissons pas non plus le
temps ça a été fixé aujourd'hui du sénat
mais je parle des comptonales des
régionales quelle date quel mode de
scrutin
quel territoire vous rendez compte cette
démocratie et territoires dont le sénat
est l'incarnation
nous n'avons aucune vision d'avenir on
peut pas dire aujourd'hui un maire les
régionales les copains les régions où je
peux pas vous dire quand auront lieu les
élections et je ne peux pas vous dire
sur quelle base auront lieu que le cvec
souffrent et je pense que le sénat est
aujourd'hui je pense que le sénat doit
occuper sa place
il doit être plus rapide plus véloce il
doit être plus imaginatif mais vous êtes
aussi politiquement résister la
république devrait avoir face à lui un
président du sénat qui aujourd'hui lui
dise ce dont nous avons besoin sur les
territoires et puis aussi sur la
démocratie transparence
quelle est l'action hollande quand vous
serez président du sénat c'est ce que je
dis à françois on a chaque fois que je
peux leur encontre et là effectivement
c'est le discours d'un candidat que vous
tenez pour la présidence du sommet
c'est le discours d'un sénateur qui
tient sa dignité qu'ils n'aiment pas
apparaître dans la vie politique comme
un subalterne
ça fait longtemps qu'on voit les
pouvoirs et les responsabilités du sénat
progressivement décliné la république a
besoin du ces
à elle a besoin de gens modérés elle a
besoin de gens qui connaissent le
terrain de gens elle a besoin de ces
mêmes voulait pas dévoiler un peu vos
ambitions pour le snap que nous avons
c'est le masque est alors qu'on vous
voit quand même un peu en campagne sur
la jument jusqu'à je n'avance pas masqué
si vous me demandez si je suis candidat
je vous répondrais probablement mais il
est clair que l'évolution sémantique bon
parce que vous êtes très attentif à tous
les maux mais il est clair que je suis
quelqu'un qui a une vision bi
probablement qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
découragez qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
empêcher d'être candidat à la présidence
du sénat et bien que par exemple ce qui
serait très dommageable pour nous que la
droite et le centre ne viennent pas la
majorité
donc moi je veux tout faire pour qu'il y
ait une majorité au sénat donc je ne
veux pas faire de cette alternance
je ne sais pas je ne pense pas mais je
ne sais pas je suis vigilant mais pour
moi la candidature qui s'affiche dans
une ambition personnelle à un moment où
ce qui compte c'est l'alternance au
sénat ce qui compte c'est une vision
pour le sénat une pensée pour le sénat
et le retour à la dignité des sénateurs
est donc cette dignité des sénateurs il
faut la défendre
donc ça c'est mon projet je veux le
faire partager
mais je prendrai les décisions
définitives en tenant compte de la
situation car nous verrons nouvelles
morts dans 30 ans compte de la situation
politique parce que nous sommes dans une
majorité qui est extrêmement serré et je
suis contre les divisions très bien je
peux le dire d'une future majorité qui
serait sans doute très serré moi je suis
content les divisions je le montre à
l'ump aujourd'hui c'est moi qui avait
rapproché copé et fillon pour éviter un
certain nombre de difficultés à un
moment c'est moi qui parle avec les uns
avec les autres
je suis quelqu'un qui rassemble je suis
pour qu il y ait dans ce projet
sénatorial un collectif et qu'une
candidature exprime selon les
estimations là si on a compris les actes
qu'on serait là même compris des
excellents je vous le disais petite
question rapidement si j'ai le temps
pour finir jean pierre raffarin à bord
sur le budget
des armées parce que là encore c'est un
peu flou et françois hollande laisse
traîner la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat demande aujourd'hui
à l'unanimité le respect de la loi de
programmation militaire vous soutenez
cette déclaration absolument absolument
autour du président carrère nous sommes
tout à fait convaincu que le travail des
effets présents socialiste mais qui sait
travailler avec les uns avec les autres
et nous avons beaucoup négocié sur cette
loi par la somme était à certains
d'entre nous l'ont voté pas touche
mais il ya eu un travail collectif qui a
été menée ce vote là doit être respectée
et nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
respecte le loi votée par le sénat est
ce que vous avez été surpris par le ton
de la lettre adressée par le ministre de
la défense jean yves le drian à françois
hollande justement pour lui demander de
défendre le budget des armées ssa un ton
très dur ça s'apparente mm un
réquisitoire
c'est un peu dur quand on pense que le
chef de l'état et chef des armées c'est
à dire qu'il est en première ligne sur
ce sujet donc il y avait un ton qui
étaient un ton un peu culpabilisant
c'est seulement en effet surpris de la
part de monsieur le drian qui est un
personnage tout à fait respectable et en
général autant modéré mais ça veut dire
vraiment que la menace était forte et
donc il faut pas faire de reproche à
monsieur le drian mais s'inquiétait de
la manoeuvre qui était en cours de
préparation
il avait raison sur le fond il a
entièrement raison sur le fond je pense
que le président de la république a dû
faire très vite les arbitrages
nécessaires
j'imagine j'imagine qu'ils alors on y va
non seulement en interne au gouvernement
j'imagine que le président de la
république a pris sa respect il est le
chef des armées c'est lui qui engage nos
forces sur des théâtres d'opérations qui
sont très risquées
donc c'est lui qui est le premier
attentif à l'aspect sauvage et réarmer a
raison et vous même de reconnaître